ever the MSG sphere in Las Vegas takes
things to a whole new level the sphere
features the largest high resolution LED
screens in the world providing an
immersive visual experience that can be
seen from any seat inside or outside of
the venue located proudly in the heart
of Las Vegas this colossal structure is
unlike anything you've ever seen it's
not just the immersive size that's
impressive it's also the immersive
experiences it promises to provide we're
talking about the ultimate entertainment
Hub with state-ofthe-art audio and
visuals all in one space so what's the
challenge with this extravagant project
well that's what we're here to uncover
as we explore the MSG sphere further
we'll unveil the architectural hurdles
and the innovations that accompany it
while understanding its origins of
course